so when was the last time that you wrote
a handwritten note has probably been a
while technology has changed the way we
communicate we send emails not letters
text messages not phone calls you order
delivery instead of cooking dinners in
our kitchen all in the name of
efficiency but here's the point
technology has made it easier to
communicate but it hasn't made it easier
to connect with other human beings I
found that the secret to connecting in
the high-tech fast-paced world that we
live in is doing a few small things the
old-fashioned way write a letter I've
written thousands of handwritten notes
thanking people for advice thanking them
for an interview just push that extra
effort to show someone that you really
care and that you're willing to go above
and beyond some advice for writing a
thank-you letter it's to really make it
clear to the person that you're writing
to the impact that they have had on your
life talk about something specific
like thank you for the advice that you
gave me it's because of the advice you
gave me then I am now doing X people are
looking to make a difference and so if
you can show someone that they've really
had an impact on the life that you're
living the life you're pursuing it can
have a huge impact pick up the phone and
dialing we've hired thousands of
employees and I've personally called
every single one of them to welcome them
to the compass family I'm able to set
the tone of really what I want the
company to be where you know people go
above and beyond to make people feel
welcomed and to give people a sense of
belonging and sometimes I call people on
their last day of work when people leave
sometimes they're more transparent than
they ever were when they were actually
still at the company and so it's a great
opportunity to get the kind of feedback
that it's very hard to get otherwise ask
interesting and meaningful questions
when you get outside of the office when
I'm travelling the country every single
night I'll have a dinner with people in
the company I like to ask questions like
what's your underlying motivation what's
something that happened this week that
meant a lot to you and when you go
around the table and people really open
up and people are able to engage it sets
a different tone when people come back
to the office they can see each other
and they know each other in a deeper way
answer questions the honesty
you know how it feels need go into an
elevator and someone says how was your
weekend it could have been like the best
weekend ever you could have met the love
of your life the person you want to
marry and you would say good how was
yours if you want to connect with people
then you have to open up I'm not always
that good at it and I imagine most
people aren't but that's why being open
stands out so much because most people
aren't turn the video on I would always
recommend a video conference over a
phone call because that's when you can
see the real personality come out when
you're on video you're forced to be
present it's almost a forcing mechanism
to be in the moment nobody succeeds
alone the more you can take time to
develop genuine authentic relationships
the more you're gonna be able to realize
your dreams because you're going to be
able to take big risks and know that
there's gonna be a network of people out
there to cheer you on and to support
your efforts
[Music]